what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Stone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y go Sophia hello everybody and welcome
back to another episode of the unwax
podcast can I just say it without you
every do you realize there hasn't been
one time that I have done this intro
without you actually looking at me like
I've messed it up and every single time
well this time you had a voice crack you
sound like you're going through puberty
[__] okay I can start again go again
okay hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters cinee can I
say my name sinee and Sophia your makeup
looks good considering you were just
crying 10 minutes
ago can I give you I just told you 5
minutes prior can we not talk about how
I teared up no you know what Sophia
we're kind of call ourselves unwaxed we
need to be honest with the listeners
it's
okay we can we can say it it was snowing
for the first time since we moved here
it's our first New York snow you guys
which is really exciting I was really
happy and Sophia I see her staring out
the window and she's crying like a
single tear coming down her face go why
why you crying it was our first snowfall
in the city I just I don't know it's
everything came up where I was thinking
this is such a pivotal moment we're in
the city I remember I looked out the
window and I said what are we doing here
that's true I but I do admire the way
that you look at life you truly think
that you're living in a romcom all the
time all the time I try to romanticize
everything to the best of my ability
that's cute I have to well well why not
like looking at the snow I had tears of
joy looking at snow even though it
really didn't it wasn't necessary
obviously but Sophia saw tears of joy I
saw a man downstairs making yellow snow
we we see things differently but that's
why we work together well exactly but
you know what the snow did remind me of
that it's almost Christmas yes which is
alarming because one I don't even think
I finished my last New Year's resolution
I couldn't even tell you what it is what
was it don't know I think I remember
mine and I'll tell you what it was
interesting because I I make resolutions
but I don't really make resolutions I
don't follow through with them but when
I was on my on the trip with my ex and
they had this whole family tradition
where they say trigger warning not I
thought it was actually a cute idea that
they did and because they hold each
other accountable they tell with the
whole family like three things that they
personally want to achieve and then the
following year they asked did you
achieve those three things and what
three things are going to achieve this
year the pressure I know which I kind of
love I was thinking wow that that
actually so good because you have
someone else accountable so I think I
said I was going to start my book I
think I was going to acclimate into the
city as fast as I could I don't remember
any of mine well that means you didn't
we have to hold ourselves accountable I
just think New Year's resolutions are a
lot of pressure and I try to minimize my
um unsatisfaction towards the end of the
year when I realize I haven't complete
any of them by choosing resolutions that
are the easiest to accomplish I just
don't make being very vague about I'm
like I'll start my book that here's a
life hack if you don't hold yourself
accountable to certain things you won't
disappoint yourself so don't
goals that's really helpful for um have
you started buying Christmas presents
okay I wanted to get into this because
you were just saying Christmas is coming
around and I am in the category that I
hate gift giving I hate it I am so
stressed out trying to figure out what
you Four Women Want For Christmas Dad I
can give them a mug with the handle
being a fist and he'll be happy like you
and Mom and Dad Scarlet are so tough
here's the thing I think you try to do
gifts that are really personalized and
special and memorable yeah you like to
give experiences I yeah I always do that
the last two years though both of two
one last Christmas we couldn't go to the
concert you got me the Christmas before
that you said a pole dancing class that
we never did we never did no for I
changed it under the tree P dancing
class no no no no no no I changed pole
dancing class to the Arctic Monkeys
concert which therefore we couldn't go
because we were working so therefore I
took the money from that got a ticket to
the 1975 my favorite she took my gift
and gave it to herself I regifted it and
brought it back to myself but it's
really not that complicated see I'm a
little OCD when it comes to gift giving
cuz I like everything that I give
someone to be something that they
actually need or have said that they
wanted so I will literally start taking
notes in January if you say oh I really
love these like brown Adidas shoes I'll
write down sopia brown Adidas shoes so
then when Christmas comes around you
won't expect you don't talk like that
with me like I'll just say it passing by
you usually kind of execute and find a
way to get it or a better version I
literally sent you screenshots me one
screenshot of an Ugg boot she
wants all I want are Uggs and S you guys
can't get them for you they're sold out
figure out a way there's chist Miracle
I'm not gonna go talk to the head of
Uggs and get you your
Sherpa cortero colored Uggs like I can't
do that that's what's also an classic
normal ones I'm the type of person just
ask me I told you this the other day I
said ask me Sur listen I said ask me
what I want I have 10 screenshots of
things in my phone that I actually want
she goes no I want to be surprised but
these are the things I want so why not
yeah but you guys also are that kid that
gets an a avocado for Christmas and goes
thanks if it's something that you don't
want that much that's why I'm saying let
me help you I think it's better to be
surprised like I I'm just I'm better at
letters I'm the letter writer of the
family I truly am great I've written
your anniversary letter to your
boyfriend I've written Scarlets for her
anniversaries I've written moms for
Dad's everyone's birthday cards so I can
do that like if you want to hire me for
like a really good sentimental tear
jerker I got you let's rewind
let's rewind um can I explain the
anniversary thing
yes do you remember in the beginning of
your relationship like the first five
months you're in such a honeymoon phase
and everything is just Bliss yes well my
ex and I did anniversary cards every
single month okay so by the time it hit
month 8 I started repeating old cards
and I was like oh my God I'm getting
repetitive so yes you did help me I
needed some new words in my vocabulary a
couple times yours were way better than
mine actually the ones that you wrote to
my ex unknowingly obviously he said
those were his
favorite that's so good and that's what
I even with Scarlet I just I actually
realized I gave her some tips I doubt
her boyfriend listens to this I gave her
some tips on what she should focus on
that men really like like I know exactly
what your boyfriend would want to hear
yeah um I can kind of give some that I
usually think always for one thing bring
up very specific details about them that
only they know that you would notice
like very it can be for me I have
freckles on my lips like things like
that or guys like to be told that
they're I I I don't like to say boys or
anything tell say that they're a man
that they protect you that you feel safe
with them things like that that you know
that they usually lead into and I'm
trying to think what else it's always
involving the wording of I can't imagine
my world without you or or things of you
were exactly what was a blessing in my
life this year or I I don't know I'm
trying to think what else I've said to
you guys I just I think oh also bring up
specific moments oh oh this is the catch
it's when you remember those moments
maybe you looked at them at a long like
maybe you were at a party and you guys
gazed at each other from across the room
and maybe there was a moment that you
both share where you just smiled and
laughed at each other um and it just was
a pass by but you remember it if you
write down that specific moment like I
knew the moment that I when we looked at
each other at this holiday party and we
smiled at each other not having to say
any words that you were going to be my
person forever because I wouldn't have
any I didn't need to say any words for
us to share our emotions with each other
from acoss it's like that type of thing
yeah
ex yeah so um obviously that was a very
rough rough draft of what I would
normally go to really nice thank you you
know what I think I'm a little
disappointed in us why for one it's
winter it's snowing it's wied up winter
yeah we have no prospects you were
convinced through Tik Tok that you're
going to find your husband by December
that hasn't happened because I saw one
psychic on Tik Tok say wow wait your
December is going to be filled with
boyfriends and so I think I watched it
and then that just kept popping up
because the algorithm just kept bringing
it back but my dulu state I was thinking
oh this is happening I told my mom my
mom don't worry I'm going to get over
this heartbreak because it's I'm going
to find another guy by December and of
course by the way have not had a date in
eons and cinee has like eight this week
you
guys it is so true when they say it
rains it poures yeah but then to be fair
it's not like I'm meeting these people
in different places it's all on a dating
app which is great I it's very condensed
but yes I have two dates this weekend
one on Friday one on Saturday a few
things one would it be weird if I wore
the same outfit to both because you you
know when you have a great date outfit
and I pretty much wear this one outfit
for every first date it's safe I know it
looks good do smell bad and stuff like
what if you you think I just smell bad
no no I was going to say like nervous
sweats that's just you boo I get nervous
that's just you you don't get like
nervous a little bit I just get hot so
I'm like drenched okay so you think it's
normal you think it's fine oh yeah I
don't think it's bad I'm really excited
about both these men I know you really
are and they they're good options
they're really cute they're older
they're older they haven't been here
long so they haven't seen enough girls
for their their heads to be S see one of
them one of them just moved here I'm
snatching his ass right up perfect
perfect like Lally he's moving in to day
I am today tomorrow yesterday I'm trying
to convince you to go on a dating app I
know I know I know I know wait actually
I don't know if that's a great idea for
you because why I just want to give an
example of yes right now amazing that I
have two dates it's only taken eight
months of being on the app no that's not
true sop when was the last time I went
on a Hing date you've had hinge dates
like probably not even maybe four months
ago but you have to realize a lot of
people don't date that frequently I feel
like I've heard so many girls that I've
talked to that are single go I haven't
been on a date in 7 months I haven't
been on a date in 8 months and we just
we just are frequent or right not you
frequent daters yes you know so our our
um our lag is like 3 months that's like
not that much this app is so weird Hing
is so weird I hate hate hate the voice
when the guys do the voice note yeah I
knew you're going to say that why
they're shootings in the foot with that
why are they doing it how about this no
I'll give you an example I'm so I'm on a
roll right now oh he did I get a message
from a guy right we're talking casually
and then he just sends me
[Music]
this what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to do with that was that the
Tasmanian devil what did you MCH with I
was literally thinking am I supposed to
reverse it and that's what he's really
trying to say is is he speaking in
tongue right now like what is this
Morris code [__] like why they're so
strange seems like yes what the No No No
it's it's you know what I I've seen so
many times is when the guys they they
think they're so funny with oh how do
you pronounce my name and then they'll
send like a pronunciation of someone
else and like my name is Juan when their
name is Matthew I just stop like I I
just can't it's it's not funny anymore I
I get what you're trying to do just put
a cute photo up say you love golden
retrievers and it's so simple dog
picture cool selfie friends out I mean
that's it oh I can this is I'll tell you
the most cated perfect dating profile
for a guy if a guy is wondering what to
do open up with a really good photo of
you not a business photo not you not one
that you use on LinkedIn yes do use your
LinkedIn head shot don't use your
LinkedIn HG shot I know I know it's hard
some like a lot of girls we just take a
lot of photos so we have a lot of photos
of ourselves but one just find one good
wedding photo usually guys use their
openers as wedding photos with their
friends which is fine you can do it with
a guy friend it's cool the second one
should be with maybe your dog or with
your family or another one with friends
but not you at a day Club holding a cup
of orange liquid that we all know is not
water or Gatorade three go in with like
an active pick you at the beach you
running you but not not like the marath
the marathon's fine but like I guess
just a snowboarding something where it
just shows that you're out and about you
jumping off a cliff like who you're in
Fiji or something and then in terms of
the prompts it's the same answers that
they give we'll get along if you let me
roast your
profile like I mean no look in In
fairness answering the prompts are hard
but so just go easy with it just just be
just be you you don't have to be super
funny girls aren't I I think things are
witty if you can just naturally have a
witty answer to things it's great I also
think I used a lot cuz I wouldn't say my
I remember when I did hinge like no I
didn't do hinge I think it I think it
was I don't know what I did but I
answered a question and I brought up the
fact I used to play with um uh what's it
called B Bionicles so use that like
about how there's something that made me
goofy did in the past and I was like oh
I used to play Bionicles that one was
the biggest one because every guy was
like you used to build bionic such a p
me you're such a p that's a pck me yeah
I used to build like Rob if it was a pck
me I had 40 I had EAS and you know that
they were all over Dad's no we we had a
lot of fun had that's my suggestion for
if you guys are lost on how to perfect a
dating profile I'm just so excited I
feel like Samantha Jones in Sex in the
City do you have a favorite Friday I
think I do I'm G to call him Friday and
Saturday Mr Saturday Mr Saturday is
bigger why because we've been actually
texting the other guy hasn't asked me
for my number so we've only been
communicating through the app but Mr
Friday followed up like weeks later cuz
we were both out of town so he didn't
forget you know he could have just left
me in the messages I don't know
sometimes the ones you don't think are
going to be the better one is usually
the better one in and they look totally
different one's blonde one's brunette
but they're both the same age they're
older than you which is nice I know I'm
excited I know I'm excited you know oh
remember I brought this up to you last
night that we have to do it now that you
have like these two options so there's a
there's a not a tradition but there's a
thing that people do on New Year's Eve
is when the clock strikes 12 you go
under a table you eat 12 grapes and you
wear red
thongs before 12:1 and so that's
supposed to like manifest of
relationship again Sophia I've seen so
many Tik toks of this video of a woman
saying you eat 12 grapes you wear a red
thong and when the clock strikes
midnight you're going to find your next
relationship
what kind of pervert came up with that
I'm sorry like that's like a weird
specific fetish naked wearing a 12
grapes what if you accidentally ate
11 well then that doesn't work it's eat
12 what if the thong is maroon does it
still work no it has to be red all right
well do you have a red thong you can
wear that's a little much I'm not
answering that question I bed the fif
the um I want to talk about my trip to
London oh that's right the last episode
I said oh I'm going to go on a work trip
for one day but make it a spontaneous
trip for
myself I've realized that I hate
traveling alone I hate it I was so
lonely I didn't know where to go I
didn't know what to do I ate in the
hotel every night I was so boring you
could have easily gone to a nice
restaurant sat at the bar had a glass of
wine and just enjoyed the scene but
there's something about being in a new
city that it's for me the memory holds
longer when you're sharing it with
someone when you're experiencing that
with someone I understand that but I do
have to say I love British people so
much they're lingo they're slang there's
just one guy for example I was walking
down the street and this is just the
difference between like an English guy
and a New
Yorker he I'm walking down the street
and he goes you look mental but in an
accent like you look mental right good
thing by the way if a guy in New York
said that to me I'd say that is the
meanest thing you could say but a
British boy called calling me mental
well mental for them is mental here is
like you're clinically insane like you
yeah I would say you're such an [__]
I'll probably throw a drink on him but I
was like I look mental what would you
have done that would have been better
with someone versus just being alone why
didn't you spend that one day you were
alone it wasn't like a week you were
with you with yourself for one day one
day too long see when I'm alone for too
long all my intrusive thoughts start to
creep in okay then that's that's dark no
I I just think that it's when you're sh
shoing or getting a coffee or you're
going to lunch like it's just more fun
to do it with someone yeah I I agree but
I also for me I if it was one day I
think it would have been just nice to
just you know you have your own schedule
you don't have to go on anyone's time
you can just enjoy listening to your I
almost went to the Shrek Museum cuz I
really didn't know what to do with
myself that's that's a low Point that's
like the last place out of every place
you could have gone to in London you go
to the Shrek
Museum it's actually it's like an
interactive thing too oh no there's a
little roller coaster in there I should
have gone no you shouldn't I'm so happy
you said you didn't wait while you were
in London I just remembered something
something happened to me when I was at
the house that has never happened to me
before in my life okay my brain oh went
on overload and got so hot from from not
being able to process information and
let me explain huh let me explain so I'm
on my phone and I was watching some
videos and suddenly A video popped up
and this guy shows basically he cannot
believe this is my brain actually came
came out of my ears like I had steam so
it showed someone just like laying on a
grass field and then it just pulled back
and it was one of those basically like
let's show you how like big Earth is and
then Mars and then this and then the
moon whatever okay so it just kept going
back and I just kept watching it just
kept going and going and it pulled back
out of our solar system and then it
pulled back the milk and then and then
all of a sudden we have like a trillion
galaxies and then we keep going back
there's a gazillion galaxies and then my
brain was thinking what is any of this
like where where are we what what is
this like
pull it is too early listen list so we
just our solers that we pull back then
it's our galaxy and then around us are
like thousands of galaxies and then back
those there's gazillions of galaxies and
then back there's a drill and it keeps
expanding but what is what is anything
like where where are we where are we
like I actually was talking to I was on
the couch with Mom and Dad and I kept
going to Mom like Dad Mom like where are
we what is this what is this place like
we're just floating where where not even
in our galaxy do you think where do you
think oh my God yeah
like I can't process this like there
there has to be life out there I mean
there's gazillions of solar system
systems and we're thinking we're the
only one no I think we know we're not
the only one there's other life on other
planets but do you think
that you know how we have VR simulation
and we could see another life through a
different lens what if we are the
simulation and it's actually aliens
running us I'm not no they're watching
us like we're not in a simulation
because we went into that like it's big
brother for them no we we definitely
aren't in a simulation we're definitely
light years behind all the other
galaxies that maybe know about us and by
the time we can even see another galaxy
apparently it's going to be way too far
for us to even gain so we're never going
to I really don't think we'll ever Truly
find life on another planet maybe a
little bit maybe somewhere eventually
but just where are we floating sop
you're making my head hurt like where no
but truly like think about all the
darkness where are we what where what is
the meaning of anything we're in a
podcast studio in New York but that's
what's it it made my brain hot thinking
about it kind of put things in
perspective I'm like what is the meaning
of anything you know like what what is
the meaning of this what is I don't know
Sophia you're asking the wrong girl I
don't know I'm just trying to dig
floating in something like we said space
but what is where
where are
we can't handle it Sophia but I told you
can I continue with my London
conversation my brain got so hot from
hearing this and my mom and I mom and I
got into a spiral she sent it out to
eight of her friends going where are
we I was dying so yeah wait what okay
talk about Lon was what was the where
where did that come from I was just
sitting on while you were in London I
was Mom and Dad I was just sitting on
the couch and I saw basically the
vastness of space and he just get
pulling and pulling yeah and I was just
think where what is all that where are
we like what are we I can't even get
into it right now see see I'm freaking
out well another thing I love about
London
is else the TV shows do you know what
show I'm talking about love Island nope
it only can play in the UK there's
nothing like it in the states and every
time I go I have to turn it on and only
comes on around 2 in the morning there's
this show and I know we've talked about
it before
actually you know what I've realized I
hate traveling alone but there's
something so amazing about having your
own hotel room being in a bathrobe and
just allowing yourself to be a lazy slob
in bed with room service there and no
one to judge you I had this my favorite
show on TV I had WWE on my computer and
no one could judge me and I loved that I
took a bath I took a I hate baths why do
you hate baths why who wants to just sit
in their own Gunk for 4 hours well you
say you're smelly so that's on I didn't
say I was smelly I just said I got
nervous when I would go on dates but my
like I just it's you're just basically a
carrot and a pot boiling like a stew
like you're stew like you get pruny
there's no broth in there it's a bubble
I don't understand baths I by way I I go
crazy when I'm in a bath anyway there
was the show on TV called naked
attraction okay the premise is
absolutely insane I cannot believe that
this is allowed on cable tv anywhere but
it's the best show ever it starts with
one either female or male contestant
with the host and then behind a curtain
are five males or females or both the
curtain raises right you see feet you
see calves and then it raises all the
way up to their belly button full Bush
Out full dingdong out no sensors no
blurring and then the host and the
contestant choose which one to eliminate
CU they don't like it and then the
curtain raises and then it goes to their
neck you see breast you see pecs and
then they choose two more to eliminate
and then they say oh can you do a spin
for me can you I mean it is insane and
then the best part is cuz you're
probably thinking well why can one
person clothed stand there judging all
these naked bodies when it comes down to
two more contestants the
person has to take their clothes off
come back out so now it's the three of
them on the stage in front of a live
studio audience Stark naked and then the
two people that she or he has been
judging can say whether they are
attracted to him or
her talk about about a confidence killer
I don't also think like I just don't
know how that was pitched and how that
went from the it's this think about how
the process of the show being made some
man I'm assuming or woman who
knows thought of this idea let's have a
dating show where everyone's Stark naked
no when I tell you nak they judge each
other on their bodies and then they went
to some production company said the same
thing and they green lit it and then
went to some Network
and they thought genius like that and
then they built a whole studio there's
20 seasons of this no I know I remember
I remember watching it it's just I don't
think I would I don't think anyone looks
great in like Stark lighting like I know
Studio lighting I'm saying like I would
look like [__] people like oh it's so
crazy but here's the here's the weird
thing that sort of happened while I was
watching this so I had the show naked
attraction on my computer I had WWE on
the TV and it's about 2:30 3 a.m. and
the TV has a commercial right so I'm
still watching naked attraction on my
computer all of a sudden I hear a very
familiar voice on the TV it's like what
like I'm a little out of it I'm
melatonin in I'm like what what huh
mhm Dad's face is on a commercial and
he's talking on the TV as I'm staring at
naked bodies on my computer watching the
show I'm like I feel like I feel like he
knows I feel like I'm being watch I
thought you were just gonna say Dad was
on the show I was like what you imagine
I heard a familiar voice when the
curtains went up and it was my dad's
voice that was I was literally I just
shut my computer I was like I can't that
was too weird a little I felt like I was
caught for doing something wrong that is
really odd I know that's I couldn't
handle that either I know to change
topics there's something I why are you
laughing
nothing life is not a waste of time time
it's not a waste of life so let's stop
wasting time let's get wasted and have
the time of our lives you
guys Sophia Sophia finally is stopping
her 75 hard no drinking sobriety thing I
did so I said we must go out to dinner
and have minimum three cocktails finally
my drinking buddy is back so we went to
this bar had some food made friends with
the bartender was getting a little
Swifty yeah and we spent about 30
minutes of this dinner trying to
memorize the cheers that went viral 30
minutes it's Sophia us drunk we could
not remember it pull did this cheers
that went viral okay let's see if we
remember ready time is not a waste of
life and life is not a waste of time so
let's stop wasting time get wasted and
have the time of our lives it's a genius
you need an extra 10 minutes on that one
yeah that one's a great cheers that one
gets the party going you think we we
said it it easily 15 times like we like
every sip we had we kept saying it as a
practice it's genius it was so good um
okay so I wanted to talk about something
that I've been thinking about and I
wanted to know if you felt the same way
cuz I I called my girlfriend because
I've been feeling a little
bit I feel off I feel off I woke up the
other day and I felt really off and not
not physically off just I think mentally
off you talking about yesterday no I was
fine yesterday oh I was off yesterday so
were you off yesterday well I'll talk
actually that's why I did ask if you
were okay can I can I also maybe ask
this to the to the
crowd to a live studio
audience does it also piss you off when
you woke up for no reason sort of in a
bad head space a bad mood for no reason
yeah and you're trying your best to
swallow it and act normal but it's so
but someone says are you
okay that grinds my gears more than
anything way more mad it makes me more
mad cuz I like I was already
short-tempered and you don't mean to
you're not mad at them you're just mad
at the fact that they can feel your
energy and you're you feel vulnerable
[__] because I don't want it to affect
you and now that you've noticed it now
I'm out at myself tough because in I
mean real we are with each other it's
true 24 hours day every second of the
day so I know were saying I mean right
now you're a bit more on the social
scene than I'm in but it's only because
which is great by the way power to you
honey took me about 10 years to get here
no it's great I'm proud of you um but I
I called Mom about it because and I
texted uh my friend about it and she was
feeling the same thing I just am having
a really hard time committing to things
and saying yes to things not because I'm
feeling no I'm not feeling depressed I'm
not feeling like
you know what I'm feeling and this is
the best way to verbalize it I think I'm
just burnt out from this whole year and
I think the end of the year just hitting
now I'm feeling it and now I don't want
to say yes to anything like the thought
of me going to a date going to a party
um having to self motivate to get to
work and I also would like to say and I
feel like maybe people can relate to
this and just for personally me this
year has been a lot like a lot of yeah a
lot a lot like I mean going through
dealing with like a heartbreak was tough
extremely tough and it wasn't the
easiest it's been actually was probably
the hardest heartbreak I've had to go
through and then moving to a new city
having to acclimate to a whole new
environment from across the country we
had a reality show come out and then
right on top of that had to shoot
another real like we had only one month
people were like oh you went no I don't
count me us going to Italy was work we
didn't we didn't go to any restaurant we
went to one restaurant one night cuz we
work 13 hours a day we worked every
single day I don't count trips with my
ex um a vacation because no that's
that's that's more work that's 24 hours
day if you're with their family for me
personally I'm on it with their families
if if you it's a wedding it's not it's
not enjoyable it's a wedding and then
also with our with our careers and
everything it's always like you have to
do it if you don't get up you don't go
and the podcast relaunching so I think
I'm getting to the point at the end of
this year where I'm just so depleted and
everything is hitting me and maybe
that's why honestly maybe I was crying
about the snow maybe it wasn't honestly
it's always never about the snow it's
not about the snow it's not about the
snow the snow wasn't causing my teth
it's not about the pasta and it's not
about the snow I think it just was like
oh like I'm just so like I can't I I
honestly I feel like my arms are just
exhaust I can't
even I know exactly how you're feeling
and I think a lot of people can relate
one end of the year burnout is super
normal
but this is actually why I started going
to therapy because a few months ago the
idea of starting my day was exhausting
me even more yeah it was like oh my God
I have to go out do this see this person
commit to that and then if I don't do
those things I'm even more upset with
myself which puts me in an even worse
mood I mean it was this continuous cycle
and I really had to put in a lot of time
work and I do think being social and
getting yourself out of this
sort of slump that you're in one I
learned that you can't beat yourself up
because you're human and I think a lot
of the time we feel like we're the only
ones going through this and we're not
yeah and that's why I texted my friend
and asked her I said are you feeling
like this lately and she goes oh my gosh
yes I am and I think another factor of
it and um I think a lot of people can
understand this is that especially when
you're going through heartbreak or
you're in a new environment all I wanted
to do was put on the best face I didn't
want him to know that I was hurting
immensely so I went out as much as I
could socialize as much as I could I
wanted to get into a new city and be as
involved as I can showing people like
showing face it hasn't even been that
long it hasn't and it's like I'm here to
finally say like I'm so tired of having
to be always on it and okay like I
wasn't like we had to be on it for the
show we had to be on it for like being
with friends like we had to be okay okay
okay okay and I feel like I just ran
with that for the last eight months yeah
not to mention all of the personal
family things you have to go through and
the personal family stuff and things
that people don't my heart health issues
and by the way I like I'm happy that I
powered through at some points because
this year's also been the most growth
and it has been really fun in some ways
and I feel like I had a lot of
Adventures that you know wouldn't have
happened if I didn't push myself you
have to allow yourself the grace period
of just not and there's nothing wrong
with that there's no timeline there's no
okay by January 1 I have to be okay
again you actually don't it's not a
Sprint no it's not and I think the
biggest part about this is that I'm and
we are we're doing this alone when we
were going through things last year we
had someone to lean on in some way and
now with things this year you're just
like you don't have you have to lean on
yourself which is great because it shows
you like after this I'm like wow I'm
actually a lot stronger than I thought
but I I'm just I'm just exhausted like I
feel like the rest of the year I just
don't I honestly all I want to do is
escape the city and just be with my
family pets and just relax for the next
3 weeks and that's probably why my skin
broke out that's probably why I had
eczema flashes my body was freaking out
because I wasn't really being honest
with how I was feeling you know what I
would love for our
relationship I would love to get to a
place with you and I think this is so
common with siblings sometimes you just
want to see maybe because you're older
you just want to seem like you have it
all figured out and you're okay all the
time I mean most days I see you leave
the door and I can't leave I want to be
able to have this dialogue with you
where you actually say this to me
because it only makes my relationship
with you stronger it makes me understand
you more it makes me understand how to
navigate your emotions in this moment I
completely agree with you on that
because in my defense with that a little
bit I actually didn't realize I was
feeling like this until this week truly
it's almost like I've been you have to
admit it well yeah it's like I think I
had to let myself run out of steam and
go wow my steam is out like I I did and
I was and this is the thing throughout
those months I had waves you've had
waves of ups and downs and we've both
shared those things but I do feel like I
had to not even because I was genuinely
happy at some points I'm too tired to go
out and see friends I'm too tired to
even think about doing work I'm too
tired to go to the gym like it's just
I'm tired I feel like because I was go
go going and I was having fun I was
going crazy I was I was enjoying this
new life that I was you know trying to
acclimate into I'm just burnt out and
that's what it is it's not my stress
like I feel like do you think it's
living in New York I I think being in a
new city yeah this is a very very loud
city um but it's not the city that's
causing it it's just you know me like we
come to this new place we thought you
know we would throw ourselves in here
it's like you know what it is it's like
college you don't like your first year
or you're you have to understand the
routine of it and then people love the
city and I I actually love this place um
maybe not exactly the area I love but I
also just I do love the people here I
love the restaurants and I love the
environment and just the city like it's
it honestly it's one of the most
romantic places I've been and I just
romanticize everything about the City
compared to La you can't do that at all
the December burnout I'm just tired and
I just feel like lately I just want to
curl up and just sleep and be I'm not
but I'm not depressed that's the thing I
just want to make that clear then do
that I well I don't hate yourself for
doing that I'm not I think that my plan
is to spend another week here and then
we're going to go back home for the
holidays and I'm just going to enjoy
relax like making that my vacation like
being home being in the sun being with
the dogs and just well do you want me to
cook dinner tonight no I thought I was
cooking dinner today yeah but if you're
too tired I can do it I I want to do it
why cuz I like it I cooked one meal for
the first time yesterday and I'm like
it's my new identity it's good job I'm
making basically the same thing just
different language amazing yeah well I
think sorry I know I just went on a 10
minute why are you saying sorry I don't
know I I that's I just naturally do you
ever just say sorry about things like
I'll run into a wall and say why I
apologize for everything I apologize
everything I don't know I'm a people
pleaser I think that's what it is I feel
feel like I who are we pleasing these
strangers we love you on waxers but like
who are we who are we pleasing I don't
know stop saying sorry yeah unless you
have to say
sorry unless you did something bad
something bad yeah apologize listen yeah
if you ever need me to curl up in bed
with you watch the snowfall and watch
Harry Potter I'm yourish um um Goblet of
Fire you know what I want to watch with
you our next series let's do Hunger
Games God I am inate wait okay by the
way this weekend we're going to go see
the new movie I'm so down but I was
watching the first one and I'll watch it
again on the plane the other day and
then I started thinking right you know
when they're in the games mhm and they
have sponsors that bring them
stuff what do you think a sponsor would
bring you that's very personal to your
identity I have actually thought of one
I can't say say it oh I said pics what
would they drop me
truly oh man yours would be almond
butter no no no no no they would have
Dro me almond butter if I have to fight
for like it doesn't have to be for
survival like peta's getting a
switchblade and this and catness is
getting more arrows Sophia is getting me
a golden retriever
puppy realistic that's you said allm
puppy off the sky they're going to drop
RX almond butter to the sky that's what
you're going to say a dog or a book like
a couple
books so I can keep up with my book club
up in I'm in a tree live streaming hey
guys sopia needs her Instagram for book
club and reader of the month hey guys
who wants to be the reader of the month
dodging B what would yours
be probably a threepac supply of gum oh
yeah it would be a lot of Mentos gum my
flavored water drops some soup crackers
oh it would be my stuff animal winter
you can't eat winter oh you just you
can't eat gum well debatable I think it
would be my they would send me down what
I have for breakfast every morning
apples butter granola M would be like my
Aqua for my gacha my gouache my ice
roller cuz I don't want to look puffy in
front of the other contest my
Kindle just um oh I was saying this to
someone the other day because I have
really bad eyesight like I'm I'm
negative3 in both eyes I've I need to go
get you know the eye surgery soon but it
gets annoying because oh I can't wait
for you to get lay sick I always people
always ask questions like could you
survive the Hunger Games could you
survive a zombie apocalypse and I always
when I think about that I go yeah I can
survive realistically no if my contact
popped out I'm out I'll tell can't see
anything I would just hide and either
dig a hole or hide in a tree the whole
time see the it goes by weeks you can't
not drink water not eat like I can't
even look for water I we're fasting
we're fasting we're in a minute FX we're
detoxing oh no I'm down to do that oh my
God I thought you meant I'm down to do
Hunger Games and I was like what let's
go find the marathon yes okay I'm down
to I'm down to um wait so I saw this
thing on Tik Tok the other day and it
reminded me of you because you did this
back in like 2016 and now it's blowing
up on Tik Tok and seeing all these girls
and guys doing it there's this ball in
Paris it's a debutant oh God yes it's a
debutant ball I don't exactly know the
details of what it's called but it's
basically all of these kids around like
European all over the world come
together in Paris I'll explain it's a
ball that happens with in the fall of
November yeah in the fall of November
it's ball that happens in the fall in
Paris during the fall in Paris and they
choose kids that come from famous
families of actors or no it's a
whatever it is it's just yeah fashion
it's very it's always the children of
right so I'm watching these girls on Tik
Tok that are doing the ball this year
get me they look so gorgeous and it just
gave me war flashbacks to yours how bad
Sophia I'm not going to lie was so yeah
I'm not going to lie I've I didn't know
someone one could be that pale we had no
idea what fake tan was we we did not
know you had your natural dark brown
hair it was as dark as yours but like
you looked like a baby you were truly a
16-year-old no but that's what I loved
about it because 16-year-old today look
27 I that's and you look 16 so I
appreciate that and also my defense so
first off the I was dressed by ellab
which is incredible at the time I didn't
know who the hell that was I was like I
don't care that's like you thought they
were prom dress thought that's like the
equivalent of Chanel dressing you I you
could tell me it was Forever 21 and I
would know that more no but the only
reason listen any kid in that sort of
world would itch to do this but the only
reason Sophia wanted to do this was so
she could be in a tiny little corner of
Teen Vogue cuz that was our favorite
magazine at the time this is the problem
is that so when they asked me to do this
I was the youngest one because if you
look at the girls that were with me they
actually looked kind of more put
together but that was because it when I
was 16 the other girls the starting age
was 20 yeah 21 so they already were four
years ahead of me and not only that like
I was at the time my Peak my Peak
like um eating muffins in the library
like really really dorky and wait I was
my Peak eating muffins at the library
reading alone like I was a dork like I
was in my Peak dork phas I will never
forget this memory so when you're at
this ball they have to pair you up with
someone oh my God or you choose who you
want if you have a boyfriend if you have
someone that you want to bring as a
friend all the girls said I didn't I
didn't have like guys I was 16 you're
set up with some it's like an arrang I I
didn't touch a guy I was like I just
could not so they set me up with someone
that lived there and he was like what
was it he was I actually don't even know
he was probably much older his parents I
think he was like his mid 20s his
parents were asking like for your hand
in marriage let's just say it what the
funniest part is I was so gross out my
parents they have to do father Dance all
this stuff Jen and Sly had no idea what
this sort of really was it's essentially
just arranging two children from both
sort of famous families to get together
well I know I think that was just there
and Mom and Dad were like we're Le it I
I hadn't even had my first kiss yet like
that was like that's how young I was
outing myself 16 year old me hold on I
didn't have my first kiss till I was 17
really yeah M that's Don't Judge Me
Chris feel your eyes that's kind of
funny I was terrified I was terrified
your first kiss oh it was so bad and I'm
actually still friends with the guy
today really yes he he even went to USC
with you like he's super super nice I
had the biggest crush on him but I
remember it being so bad that we were in
a backyard of some like party right and
then there's um this balcony for the
second floor of the house right and I
see my girlfriend leaning over the
balcony and looking down and then I
could see her in the corner of my eyes
so I was literally giving her eyes like
oh my God this is so bad he leaves for a
second he doesn't notice her oh you're
mid kiss and she's watching well they
were like laughing my friends were like
giggling looking over right he leaves he
goes I'll be right back okay I look up I
say help me they make a monkey chain of
Limbs reach halfway down pick me up from
the backyard we scal the roof we left on
the street he comes back like yeah I
would be conf used to wait want he I
just remembered something that I said I
don't know why I did this um so you know
who my first kiss was right no shout out
Matt Matt Matt blank you're didn't die
last year I went to the wedding in Aspen
with my ex and his parents were there I
haven't seen his parents since I was in
elementary school and I just remembered
them um and they're very very sweet I
was impressed with that they come up to
me I don't know why I think I was just
nervous about the entire environment cuz
I was meeting all the friends and like I
was at a wedding with people I don't
know the first thing I said to them was
did you know your son was my first
kiss why would you say that they look at
me like what they're like first of all
they're like which one I'm like no Matt
they're like oh that's sweet I'm like
yeah um we at the movies why why I was
like why are I saying
this I always do that too like we're
stuck in a barn cuz it's was pouring
outside and they like moved the whole
wedding party inside a barn and I'm just
standing there freezing my ass I'm like
is this the wedding dress where your
dress split up the back as well yes oh
my I'll finish we'll finish this with a
bedtime story and this is actually a
good one so oh this is so bad this was
the first wedding I was going to with my
ex I was so excited to go with him like
we're peeking love we're we're going to
Aspen together he was a groomsman there
and I was like he's going be in a talk
I'm so excited he's look so handsome an
Asen I was like fabulous all right so
I'm staying in a house with a bunch of
people and I found this dress from ALC
that I've been dying to get because I
was like this would be perfect dress and
what it looks like is it's a maroonish
dress it kind of has the same cut of a
toga like if you can imagine a one
shoulder toga yeah no I mean that's the
easiest I wanted an ALC
toga she paid how much for a toga what
the hell so but it was beautiful it went
like one shoulder kind of how SE
described it and on the right side it
exposes part of my stomach just a little
bit it's like the rim is scrunched it
looks like a little ring it's a ring but
it's it's it's tasteful I'm out of skin
show not too much cuz you know leaves a
little to the imagination um so my ex
had already left and I had like already
been done I'm like oh my God he's going
to get to see me and it look beautiful
I'm so excited we get on the bus I go
with all of his friends that weren't a
part of he was cuz he was a groomsman so
I went with all of his friends that
weren't and their girlfri friends or
whatever and so I'm alone like do you
real I'm like okay okayy hanging out
having fun we're supposed to get up on a
gondola to go to this party cuz or the
wedding because the wedding the
ceremony's on top of a hill I'll just
make a long story short I get off the
party bus I steep on my dress
barely the entire ring because I said it
was scrunch snapped so I start walking
and this thing I didn't realize and when
I say my nipple pasty was out my entire
g string all the way down to my knee was
exposed when we people were getting on
the Gondola there was probably maybe 50
60 people waiting I freaked out I go
there's no I was holding it together I
go I have to go up this gondle right now
for a freaking one what am I going to do
so there was a store next by so I went
in there I said they all look at me
they're like we're about to close I'm
like
Ladies God help me ladies I like please
help a lady out I L like they're like oh
my God they're like okay we'll figure it
something out so they like L safety pit
it together it looks horrible so I'm
going at the Gonda I'm freaking out all
the guys like oh God like are you good
the girls are like are you okay I'm like
I don't know what I'm going to do we sit
we're in the wedding the party happens
after I go up to cuz every wedding the
bride has this I find The Wedding
Planner
I I'm at a wedding who I don't I don't
know the bride I go up to the wedding
planner for this party and I go hey I
know you got to focus on the bride here
I'm literally a piece of kibble compared
to the party like the whole Feast like I
am literally no one but do you have a
seam interest here that can like Focus I
love that you're like listen I know it's
the bride's day I know you were hired
and paid for by the bride and you
actually don't know and I don't know
anyone in this wedding party but I'm
going to need your assistance she was
like yeah for the this wedding Planet
had to do everything else so she's
setting up did she help you she was the
best she got the seamess the Ste just
came up immediately we went to Bath
she's stitching me she goes holy [__] I
don't know what you did I remember you
facetimed me and you're like sinee help
me I was in AA what the hell do you want
me to do I I so moral story I flashed
the entire wedding party and you went up
to your first kisses parents like that
and I told it the F my first kisses
parents that we kissed in movie
theater I dropped you off for that date
anyway we'll end it there thank you guys
so much for tuning into this week's
episode of the unwax podcast and we will
see you next Tuesday subscribe and give
us five stars if you want your questions
answered please we love you guys